Bienvenidos
a esta segunda parte de
la exposición acerca de la
fórmula cuadrática,
y repasemos muy rápido
y brevemente lo que discutíamos.
La fórmula cuadrática
nos sirve para encontrar
las raíces o los 0 de un polinomio cuadrático,
de un polinomio de grado 2.
Entonces decíamos que si teníamos un polinomio
de grado 2, en su forma más general,
era algo de la forma
"a" donde "a" es
una constante
por "x" al cuadrado
más "b"
por "x"
más "c"
que sería el término independiente,
y lo que queremos hacer es
igualar esto a 0.
Y lo que nos dice la fórmula cuadrática es, que bueno,
si tienes esto y quieres resolver esta ecuación,
entonces vas a tener 2 soluciones,
vas a tener que "x"
va a ser igual a
-b
más menos
la raíz cuadrada
de "b" cuadrada
"b" cuadrada
-4 veces "a" por "c",
-4 veces "a"
por "c".
todo eso dentro de la raíz cuadrada
y a todo esto lo vamos a dividir
entre 2 veces,
2 veces "a".
Así que ahora voy a hacer más ejemplos
para tratar de clarificar cómo se usa esto.
Bien comencemos con el polinomio,
-9x al cuadrado menos 9x
más 6
y voy a querer que este polinomio
sea igual a 0
¿Para que valores de "x" esto es igual a 0?
¿Cuáles son las raíces de este polinomio de aquí?.
Y bueno lo que me dice la ecuación cuadrática es
simplemente van a ser estas las raíces
pero bien,
¿Quién es "a" en este caso, en este ejemplo?
"a" siempre es el coeficiente
de "x" al cuadrado,
el coeficiente
de "x" al cuadrado es -9,
entonces "a" es igual a -9.
¿Qué hay de "b"?
"b" es el coeficiente de "x",
en este caso es -9,
también,
noten que aquí llevo un más,
por lo tanto aquí
"b" tiene que ser igual a -9,
y "c"...
"c" es el término independiente,
por lo tanto "c"
en este caso es igual a 6.
Entonces simplemente
voy a sustituir
estos valores en la fórmula cuadrática
y voy a obtener que "x"
va a ser igual a
-b que sería menos -9,
menos -9,
más menos,
la raíz cuadrada de
"b" al cuadrado que es -9 al cuadrado,
que es 81
menos 4 veces
menos 4 veces "a",
que sería - 9
por "c" que sería 6,
todo eso dentro de la raíz,
dividido entre
2 veces "a",
que sería 2 por -9.
¿Cuánto es esto?
Menos por menos me da más,
así que esto es 9
más menos
la raíz cuadrada de 81.
4 por 9 es 36
y menos por menos es más,
así que tengo 36 por 6
36 por 5 es 180,
más 36 sería 216
así que 81 más 216...
216,
y todo eso lo voy a dividir entre -18.
Así que esto es 9 más menos
la raíz cuadrada de
81 más 216 sería 297
¿me parece?
¿297?,
sí así es,
entre -18.
Ahora bien creo que aquí puedo factorizar un 9,
veamos
2 más 7 es 9, y 9 es 18
que es divisible entre 9 así que,
297 es divisible entre 9,
¿y cuántas veces va 9 en 297?
Pues veamos 9 va en 29,
va 3 veces
me sobran 2,
bajo el 7, 9 va en 27 otras 3 veces
y me sobran 0, así que,
esto es lo mismo que...
bueno voy a cambiar de color
para romper la monotonía...
9 más menos,
la raíz cuadrada de
9 por 33,
la raíz cuadrada de 9 es 3,
así que esto es lo mismo que
3 veces la raíz cuadrada de 33,
entre -18
de modo que,
si ahora,
si ahora simplemente divido
todo entre 3 obtengo,
9 entre 3 es 3
más menos
ese 3 se cancela,
más menos la raíz cuadrada de 33.
Entre -18 entre 3,
es "a" menos 6.
Entonces aquí están mis 2 soluciones,
tengo 2 soluciones a partir de esto,
una para el signo más
y una para el signo menos
que incidentalmente,
tengo un signo más y un signo menos,
precisamente porque la raíz cuadrada,
puede ser positiva o negativa
pero bueno,
entonces mis dos soluciones son
x1 va a ser igual a 3 más
la raíz cuadrada de 33
entre 6,
y x2 va a ser igual a
3,
ah perdón -6,
me comí el signo,
3 menos
la raíz cuadrada de 33
entre -6.
Estas son,
las 2 soluciones a esta ecuación.
Son las dos raíces de este polinomio,
las 2 intersecciones con el eje "x".
Hagamos otro ejemplo,
bien consideremos ahora
-8x al cuadrado
más 5x
más 9
igual a 0.
Quiero resolver esto
y supongo que
ya se aprendieron la fórmula cuadrática
pero si no lo hicieron, háganlo
aquí la voy a poner por el momento.
Bien entonces, ¿qué me dice la fórmula cuadrática?,
pues me dice
que las soluciones
son estas de aquí
y en este caso,
tengo que "a"
¿Vale cuánto?
"a" vale -8
y "b"
¿vale cuánto?
"b" ahora vale 5.
Y "c" vale 9,
algo que debo advertirles es que
estos polinomios
podrían estar desordenados,
podría por ejemplo aparecer,
5x menos 8x al cuadrado más 9,
"a" siempre es el coeficiente
de "x" al cuadrado, "b" de "x",
y "c" es el término independiente,
ajenamente al orden
en el que aparezca escrito el polinomio.
Pero bueno,
sustituyó estos valores
en la fórmula cuadrática y obtengo
-"b" que sería -5
más menos
la raíz cuadrada de,
vamos a ponerlo aquí,
"x" es igual a
-5 más menos la raíz cuadrada de
"b" al cuadrado, que sería 25
-4ac
-4 por
"a" que es -8
por "c" que es 9.
Todo eso en raíz
dividido entre
2 veces "a" que sería
2 por -8 que es -16,
¿Ok?
¿Entonces "x" es igual a cuánto?
...vamos a cambiar de color...
"x" va a ser igual a -5
más menos
la raíz cuadrada de 25
menos,
bueno,
vamos a ver qué signo sale,
-4 por -8 es 32 positivo
32 positivo por 9
32 por 9 sería
320 menos 32
que es 288,
si mal no estoy
288,
25 más 288,
todo eso dividido entre -16,
¿y esto cuánto nos da?
Pues esto es -5
más menos la raíz cuadrada
de 25 más 288,
que sería
-5 más menos
la raíz cuadrada de 313,
todo eso dividido entre -16,
ahora bien, 313
no tiene ningún factor cuadrado,
no tiene ningún factor
que sea un número al cuadrado,
de hecho creo que
313 es un número primo,
no estoy seguro pero bueno lo que significa,
es que no puedo simplificar
más este radical,
y que entonces
mis soluciones van a ser
x1
igual a -5 y me tomo el más,
-5 más
313,
todo entre -16
y x2 de nuevo -5,
ahora me voy a tomar el menos,
menos
Raíz cuadrada de 313
dividido entre -16
y ya no puedo simplificar más
estas dos raíces,
éstas son las soluciones
a esta ecuación de aquí.
Son las raíces de este polinomio
o son las soluciones a esta ecuación.
Y bueno como último comentario,
recuerden tengo 2 soluciones en general,
siempre que este número no sea 0,
voy a tener una solución con él más
y una solución con el menos.
En videos futuros les enseñaré,
incluso a ver qué pasa cuando
lo que está dentro del radical tiene signo negativo.
Eso suena interesante,
pero bueno espero esto les haya ayudado,
y que puedan resolver ejercicios
de este estilo ustedes solos.